We've learned a lot about
derivatives, and now we will
use them to solve something
that is hopefully may
be kind of useful.
So let's just start with a
review of the chain rule,
and I'm going to write
in a different way.
So let's say I had the
function f of g of x.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going actually write this in a
way that might be a bit foreign
to you, but I think with a
little bit of explanation
you'll realize that this is the
same thing as the chain rule
that we all know and love.
I changed colors
really for no reason.
Just to change colors.
Sometimes I do that.
I'll change colors again.
The derivative of f of g of x
is equal to the rate at which
f changes with respect to g.
So that's df to dg times the
rate at which g changes
with respect to x.
And you're saying Sal, this
looks completely foreign to me.
And one, you could think
about what I just said and
I think it'll make sense.
Or I could just rewrite
this in the traditional
chain rule format.
And this isn't really
the traditional.
What I wrote is the
traditional, but the
way I've taught you.
So the way I taught you,
what's the change of
f with respect to g?
Well that's just f prime of g
of x times-- and what's the
rate at which g changes
with respect to x?
Well that's just g prime of x.
So hopefully this make sense
to you that these are just
two different ways of
writing the chain rule.
I think what was this, this is
either Lagrange or Leibniz's
notation, and this
the other guy.
But I forget.
And this actually makes sense
just from a fractions point of
view that this term and that
term cancels out and you get,
you know that this equals that
rate at which f changes
with respect x.
So with that out of the way,
let's use this to solve
something kind of hopefully
a little bit neat.
Let's say I have a cone.
Let's say it's one of
those cups you have
at the water cooler.
That's the top of the cup.
And let's say at any point in
the clone the ratio of the
radius of the cone to the
height-- if this is the
height, then the radius
is 1/2 of height.
At any point.
As you know, it's a fixed cone,
these are lines on both sides.
So that ratio stays fixed.
So just to start off with
some-- you maybe never
even learned this.
This will help us with
the problem later on.
What's the volume of-- let's
say I'm filling water
up to height h.
Let's say this is where
the water line is.
But that's where the
water is in this cone.
What's the volume assuming
that the height is h.
Assuming that I've let's say
8 centimeters of water.
What is the volume of water
that I put in the cone?
Well, if you don't know it, and
I sometimes-- well actually
later when we do rotations of
solid into integration modules
I can actually prove this to
you-- but the volume of a cone
is equal to 1/3 base times
height, where the base is
actually, you can kind of
view it as the surface
area of the water.
And what's the base?
Well that's just equal to
volume is equal to 1/3.
The base is equal to pi r
squared, where r is the radius.
This is just kind of
solid geometry review.
And what's the radius
in this case?
It's 1/3 pi r squared times h.
And in this example I
said that the radius
is 1/2 of the height.
So this equals 1/3 pi 1/2 the
height-- I just replaced it
for r squared-- times h.
We haven't done
any calculus yet.
This is just complicated-- not
complicated really-- just a
little bit hairy
solid geometry.
And if we simplify that we get
volume is equal to-- let's see.
So we get 1/2 squared is 1/4
times 1/3 is 1/12 pi, and
then h squared times
h, h to the third.
Very interesting, Now let's
start doing some calculus.
I think this might
blow your mind.
Let's say I am pouring water
into this cup at a rate of 1
cubic centimeter per second.
And for you metric jocks,
you'll know sometimes doctors
or nurses will say 1 cc, and
that's also equal
to 1 millimeter.
Just for other frames of
reference, but I like to stay
in centimeters cubed per
second because we're going
to work with centimeters
in multiple dimensions.
But let's say we're pouring
1 centimeter cubed per
second into this cup.
I want to know-- this is an
interesting question-- how fast
is the water level rising.
How fast is h changing, the
height of the water, at the
moment when h is equal
to 2 centimeters.
So how do we do that?
This just give us a static
picture of if we know the
height we can figure
out the volume.
But if we figure it out, if we
took the rate of change with
respect to time off of both
sides of this equation,
something interesting
might happen.
So let's take the derivative
with respect time
on both sides.
So the derivative with respect
to time of the volume.
Well that's just dv/dt.
And what's the derivative
with respect to time of
this side of the equation?
Well it's the rate which v
changes with respect to h.
This is v as a
function of h, right?
So it's going to be dv as a
function-- how fast does v
change with respect to h--
times how fast does h
change with respect to t.
This is just the
chain rule up here.
I want you to think about
this a little bit.
It might not seem obvious
but all we're doing
is the chain rule.
It's a little confusing because
I had no t's in this equation
before, and all of a sudden I'm
picking a derivative
with respect to t.
But let's just say that h
actually is a function of t,
which as you know it is.
So let's then just solve that.
So dv-- the derivative of v
with respect to t-- is equal
to the derivative of
v with respect to h.
Well that's easy.
The derivative of v with
respect to h is just simple.
So 3 times 1/12, that's 3/12.
That's 1/4 pi, so we can just
write pi over 4 h squared.
So that's this part.
And in this part is just
still-- see, I can rewrite
in this new color
dh/dt, times dh/dt.
So you're saying Sal,
what have you now done.
I said the rate of which the
volume is changing with respect
to time is equal to pi over 4
times the height squared times
the rate at which the height is
changing with respect to time.
So can this solve
the problem for us?
Well what do we know?
We know the rate at which
the volume is changing
with respect to time.
1 centimeter cubed
per second squared.
So we could say dv/dt
is equal to 1.
I'm going to get
rid of the units.
Most physics instructors
would cringe.
But 1 centimeter cubed per
second is equal to pi over 4.
This one is v the rate at
which the volume is changing
with respect to time.
pi over 4 h squared.
We know what h is right
now. h is 2, so it's
2 squared times 4.
We said the height is 2
right then, so 2 squared
is 4 times dh/dt.
So this cancels out, and we get
1 is equal to pi times dh/dt.
And we solve for dt/dt we
get-- let me make sure
not to confuse you.
The rate at which the height of
water is changing with respect
to time is just 1 over pi.
Fascinating.
Or 1 over pi centimeters
per second.
So we can figure out what this
number is, it's going to
be like 0.3 something.
So 0.3 something centimeters
per second is the rate at which
the height of the water level
is going to change as I put 1
centimeter cubed of volume
into this cup per second.
I have probably confused you.
You may want to
watch this again.
And I'll do a couple more
videos with these rates of
change problems because these
tend to confuse people, but
once you get the hang of it, I
think you'll see that
they're not so bad.
I'll see you the
next presentation.